[Music]
yes good in the cafe across the street
I like to apologize for the behavior of
my passion I just feel bad in my brand
for people to think that your mouths
will have been raped but the food that
they serving at this Albanian mother of
[ __ ] this mother [ __ ] sons of my
[ __ ] across the street what they be
serving is cevapi and what do you serve
here we serve the kebapi
about kimbap eat kebab is that kebapi
okay
but okay bTW about me okay bad we all
look at mouth okay
okay Buffy Buffy
Bobby come up here okay Bobby Bobby
Bobby Bobby you'll know it now you're
giving me give up give up beat you guys
and finally what is the difference
between
kebapi and cevapi but they don't know I
have to forgive them for the bastard
mother [ __ ] over there
not serving the cevapi her what in the
guild meat salt chopped red pepper diced
onion cream cosmic ice van why were you
sir
and we put in the cottage cheese the
ajvar the kajmak the cream you know
Dennis the diced onions sounds exactly
like the grilled meat meat and then we
stir and across the street
[Applause]
[Applause]
for you to try the real good food not
what is son my [ __ ] I'll make sure to
give us the five stars on Yelp
you